this is the ingram angle we start with a
big fox news alert moments ago we
learned a drone strike killed an isis-k
planner who was believed to be carrying
out future attacks according to the
pentagon also tonight the state
department once again warning americans
at the kabul airport to leave
immediately the gates are closed
for the latest we go live to the
pentagon where fox's lucas thompson is
standing by lucas well less than 48
hours after that deadly suicide attack
that killed 13 american service members
and wounded 20 others and killed over
160 afghans the u.s military has struck
back launching a drone strike in eastern
afghanistan's nanghar province that's
the headquarters of the isis in corazon
group which has carried out those deadly
attacks against those americans pete in
a statement from u.s central command
captain william urban said in a
statement quote
initial indications are that we killed
the target we know of no civilian
casualties now if you remember president
biden just a few days ago said he will
hunt down and kill whoever is
responsible for this attack it was not
clear when that would take place the u.s
military has been busy preparing to
leave the country in the next two or
three days but breaking news here at the
pentagon the u.s military has struck
back and killed an isis planner i'm told
he was traveling in a vehicle and also
killed was an associate with him
again an american drone strike has
killed an isis planner who's responsible
for carrying out potentially future
attacks against the us military not
necessarily i'm told pete was he
involved in that attack that killed uh
13 american service members yeah that
was my next question do we
we believe he was the leader or a leader
of isis k and and we don't know yet if
it's directly connected to what happened
at the airport that's right p my sources
tell me that this was an isis
k planner this is the isis branch in
afghanistan uh of course a splinter
group from the isis group in the middle
east and that he was planning additional
attacks not necessarily the attack at
the outside the kabul airport that
killed 13 american service members this
was a planner not necessarily even a
leader you notice the statement from u.s
central command it doesn't say the isis
k leader it says isis k planner got it
those words do matter in this moment but
nonetheless we're starting to hunt them
down and make them pay as the president
promised just yesterday real quick i
also saw the phrase over the horizon do
we know whether this drone strike came
from the kabul airport if it emanated
from somewhere else do we have any
information on that
we do people of course there's no drones
right now at the kabul airport these
drones fly from the middle east from
aldaph air base to the united arab
emirates it's about an eight-hour flight
into afghanistan of course you have to
fly over that air corridor in pakistan
and loiter overhead for you'd only have
about four or five hours overhead that
is where this drone strike took place it
was launched from the middle east flew
over afghanistan the only uh air assets
that are actually at the cabo airport
are apache gun ships which i know you're
very familiar with yes but could be an
indication of the type of over the
horizon capacity necessary once troops
leave on the 31st real quick any news as
well
uh lucas on intelligence uh where we may
have gotten this information from
it's just not clear right now at this
time but of course the u.s military you
know keeps a range of assets in air not
just drones but other aircraft that can
you know snoop on communications mobile
phones all kinds of things i'll just
leave it there and so it's not well
thinking after a devastating attack like
we saw yesterday in kabul the u.s
military was clearly scrambling all its
assets and to just find out who is
responsible and also who might be
responsible for other attacks in your
alert at the top of the show the state
department put out another warning
telling americans if there are any
americans outside the gates of the hotel
of the airport in kabul to exit
immediately to leave the area
immediately so it's very clear that the
u.s military and the state department do
not want crowds outside the gates and
let alone americans because of the
threat warning and general mackenzie the
head of u.s central command pete warned
that
future attacks were likely and
potentially imminent so uh perhaps this
drone strike took out a leader who is
planning a future attack uh in the next
coming days but we still have 5 000 u.s
troops on the ramp at the kabul airport
pete these are initial reports uh and
and so we don't want to get too far
ahead of ourselves and and speculate at
the same time it wouldn't be
inconceivable that intel of this type
could actually come from taliban sources
as well i mean do we know yet how linked
or unlinked these groups are i think a
lot of people lucas were jarred by the
idea that uh the taliban was willing to
let isis k fighters out of those prisons
at bagram air base calling into question
you know are these just the same people
with different flags do we know how
intel might be flowing on this
we don't know but you struck on
something very important that's uh you
know earlier today our own jennifer
griffin asked pentagon press secretary
john kirby just how many of these isis
fighters were sprung from prisons around
afghanistan when the taliban took over
john kirby said quote thousands and now
you mentioned isis and the taliban have
not always gone along the fact they've
actually fought against one another and
for years the joint special operations
command particularly the ranger regiment
were launching raids in eastern
afghanistan in nangarhar where uh isis
branch in afghanistan is based and so uh
in fact in recent years because of the
isis fighting the taliban uh there were
almost the de facto alliance the u.s was
launching drone strikes a tacit almost
alliance with the taliban a common enemy
but you cannot rule out certainly that
suicide attack yesterday that killed 13
american service members you cannot rule
out taliban involvement hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else